le géant edf est dans l'impasse
autrement dit il est en quasi faillite
et traîne une dette de plus de 41
milliards d'euros une somme qui
augmentait de 700 millions d'euros qui
ont été perdus au premier semestre du
fait de la pandémie
l'état doit donc rapidement recapitalisé
edf et a besoin d'argent de bruxelles
mais en contrepartie de ce soutien
indispensable la direction générale de
la concurrence de la commission
européenne exige un démantèlement de
l'électricien français
l' agence des participations de l'état
qui porte la participation publique de
83,6 % au capital d'edf résume les
exigences de bruxelles dans un document
confidentiel révélé par nos confrères de
reporter la position de la commission
européenne consiste à privilégier une
holding son rôle opérationnel
ni contrôle sur ses filiales et une
indépendance entre celle-ci et cette
position entraînerait la possibilité de
maintenir un groupe intégré et irait au
delà des exigences posées par les textes
européens
en lisant document on comprend qu avant
de pouvoir lui venir en aide la
commission européenne veut avant tout
s'assurer que le groupe public français
ne bénéficiera pas davantage trop
important face à ses concurrents
européens
ce plan de sauvetage baptisé hercules
par la commission a été défini en 2019
il est principal de ce plan est d'isoler
l'activité de production nucléaire et
ses risques financiers des autres
activités du groupe et c'est à ce sujet
là que les négociations se sont avérées
après compliquée depuis plusieurs mois
l'aide financière si elle est validée
permettrait de financer des dizaines de
milliards d'investissements notamment
dans le nucléaire edf et le gouvernement
français ont fait la proposition
suivante à la commission européenne
edf serait divisée en deux à edf dit
bleu pour le nucléaire et l'hydraulique
qui resterait aux mains de l'état et en
edf divers couvrant les autres secteurs
et qui pourraient être partiellement
privatisée une réforme insuffisante
selon bruxelles
mais trop radicales pour les syndicats
qui dénoncent ce plan et ses
conséquences l'avenir du secteur
électrique et donc de la transition
énergétique se négocie dans l'ombre à
bruxelles avec un seul credo sauvegarder
un simulacre de concurrence en ignorant
les enjeux techniques économiques
écologiques et industriels de ce secteur
et malgré le bilan indéfendable de cette
politique
en effet un démantèlement ne serait pas
sans conséquence pour les clients d'edf
qu'il entraînerait notamment une hausse
des factures d'électricité
les négociations sont toujours en cours
car le gouvernement a impérativement
besoin de la validation de boue sahel
pour obtenir son aide financière
le destin d'edf devrait être scellée
avant la fin de l'année